Here I've written a Python procedure called uptoten.
If the argument you pass in in less than 10,
it returns that argument, so if you pass in 5, it's going to return 5.
But it clamps values at 10. If you pass in 15, I'm just going to return 10.
I just showed you the similarity between Python and JavaScript before.
I would like you to write a JavaScript program.
Because we're going to be write a web browser that deals with JavaScript as strings,
I would like you to write your JavaScript program as one big string constant.
Call it "javascript" and submit via the interpreter.
You should declare a JavaScript function called uptoten
that takes and argument x and does exactly the same thing as this Python one.
Translate this Python code into JavaScript and then put it in this big string.